Now we can finally move
onto the main course,
how functions and
closures capture variables.
Take a close look at
the function make counter below.
The code is pretty short, but
it will require some close inspection
to understand it the first time.
What's special about this?
Well it returns a function,
an int maker.
That's OK.
There's nothing really
special about that.
We've seen that functions and closures,
and by the way here I'm using
function instead of a closure syntax
simply because the syntax is simpler.
That's the only reason.
It work exactly the same with a closure.
So we're returning a function or
a closure, remember it's the same thing.
And since functions and
closures are class objects, we can
return them from another function.
So far, that's normal.
Just like some machines
create other machines,
some functions can
create other functions.
There's nothing special about that.
What else is interesting or
at least unusual?
It has a function within itself.
So it contains a function
defined within make counter.
Well, don't panic, that's normal too.
Just like you can have machines
that contain other machines, and
these are only visible from
the within the contained machine.
Think of your radio inside you car.
So no big deal there.
And it's actually useful and good
practice to break down a long function,
not this one, but a long function,
not this one but a long function or
a complex one.
Into small,
simple functions by using interfunctions
that do part of the total job.
What else is interesting about this?
The really, really interesting and
funky part, by the way,
this should be this, is that adder.
The inner function can access this
variable that is defined before it.
Not only can it access it,
but it's changing it.
It's adding one to that,
that's what we call variable capture.
So to understand how this works, Let's
create two closures of type IntMaker
by calling twice makeCounter and
save them into two variables.
So both counter1 and counter2 take no
arguments and they return an integer.
Think very carefully what the output
should be when I call counter1 thrice.
Try to think before
using the Playground.
So the first time n will have value 0,
we add 1 and adder returns 1.
Let's see if it's true.
And what happens when I call again,
counter1?
What do you expect?
Let's give it a try.
So as you can see, when we call it
again, counter which is a type of adder,
keeps adding one to n and
that value remains there,
so we get two, three, four, et cetera.
And now for the grand finale,
what do you think this would return?
Calling counter2 for the first sign.
Think before trying it, and
as we can see, it returns one.
You might have expected
it to return four.
Actually, that would not be very useful,
because that would mean that every
function adder shares this n.
The first languages that implemented
this variable capture feature
did behave that way, but it will
soon realize that this was a bug.
It was not a feature.
So, right now,
every single closure that we return
from makeCounter takes its own copy
of all the captured variables.
So every time an adder is created,
it takes a copy of all
the captured variables.
Therefore each closure has its
own copy of the environment.
And environment means all the values of
all the variables that were captured.
This is done for safety.
And also to keep you sane.
The value of a variable will
never change out of the blue,
because somewhere,
some closure decided to change it.
Everybody has its own copy.
Let's rap up.
We've learned quite a few things about
Swift in this lesson, so let's recap.
First of all, functions and
closures are the same thing.
We just have two different syntaxes,
so you express one same thing.
Functions and closures are first
class citizens of our language.
We can treat them like any other type.
And also functions and closures capture
variables defined before the closure or
function is defined.
It might not seem obvious
to you at this point,
but those two last features make
Swift a far more powerful language.
They are the base of a different
style of programming called
functional programming.
Its popularity is
increasing a lot lately.
However, you won't need it to finish the
nano degree or even land your first job,
so don't worry, it's something that
you can learn later on if you want.
If you're interested,
you might want to check any of the books
that are linked in the instructor notes.
There are introductions to
functional programming.
And in the meantime,
we'll move to the next chapter,
which deals with Grand Central Dispatch.
This is a library that allows us to
create background tasks with great ease.
This is vital to ship great apps and
avoid being rejected from the app store.
Our newly gained knowledge of closures
would make understanding GCD a breeze.
So let's move on and learn it.